thank you so
much i would like to maybe not give
really an introduction to geometric
invariant theory which is a
technical subject but i would rather
like to introduce a few ideas
if you simply add a few simple ideas
that are
basic in the git program
and that will be useful in the gct
program also so
i will mainly
so
follow
the ideas that bernstein first tried to
explain
began to explain this morning
and explain how to use this finite
generation of
invariant algebras in order to do
geometry so the geometry will be
essentially construct cautions so there
is very general situation when you have
a
variety parameterizing some objects you
are interested in and there is a group
acting and you want to
find a modular space which is to
mount up by the action of the group so
get rid of some extra information that
you have introduced in the problem to
understand it better
and so in
when you want to do that algebraically
there are some complicated issues and so
i will discuss a few of these and
git gives you some recipe to to solve
this kind of problem
so i will be um
very basic about jit i will try to
explain how
it
can
how it comes in the gct program and what
what are the main points
that connect the two the two programs
and uh
also discuss on
uh some extensions of the results and
the finite generation we've seen this
morning that are also useful in
the gct context
so
so i will begin with a reductive group
so geo-reductive group
so you remember there are in
essentially extensions of compact groups
that are themselves extensions of
generalizations of finite groups
so we have this result that uh
let's think geometrically so right away
we will not act on some polynomial
algebra but on some
variety so suppose we have x and
algebraic already
the deduction of this group
okay so
so the most common situation so the
basic situation let's will be when this
is in
some vector space
over a field of let's say
the complex numbers to be safe
and this is algebraic already so this
means this is given by some polynomial
equations a set of solutions of some
polynomial finite number of polynomial
equations
let's say you want you want to construct
the uh the quotient
of x by g so
problem the main problem
construct
so you're an algebraic geometer so you
want to construct an algebraic variety
something close to be an algebraic
variety
let's say energy break already
why but i would like to do
x mod g so which parameterizes the g
orbits in x
of course if you forget the algebraic
structure if you
just
give you an orbit space and find put it
to put a topology on it but in general
it will
not be and it will be far from being an
algebraic variety so here the main
constraint is to find this
modular space you want to think of this
as a modular space parameterizing this
object in x this is a varieties object
index as in itself and a generic variety
so why why is the finite generation
important in this context because uh
when we have finite generation then
automatically algebraic geometers can
construct algebraic varieties
so so the thing is
so
instead of looking at all the polynomial
on the space v on the vector space v we
will look at the restrictions
on x okay so we denote the
the coordinate ring
is cool
this is like this is the image
space of restrictions functions that are
given by restrictions of polynomials
from v to x
so this is the algebra functions
on my variety that are polynomial
restrictions of polynomials and by the
uh so i can extend the results of
hilbert and the finite generation
and it follows that if g is redacted
and the invariant algebra itself is
finally generated
this is true for any uh
finally generated algebra on which the x
if you take the inverse you still get
finite generation generally financially
generated algebras in this context
the algebra of invariant
polynomial functions on x is financially
generated
and so then we have a
an algebraic variety
associated to x
that will be
the spec
of this algebra
so what does it mean
simply that
that's a kind of some notation to say
something very simple it's that we
rewrite this as a
it's finally generated so
we can choose some finite
finitely many generators
f1 to fm
we have seen in general there will be
some relations
between these uh generators
there is an idea of gender of relations
with a finite basis that's called
r
r1 to rp
okay so each one of these is in fact a
polynomial
in the generators polynomial relation
okay
and what is this respect is just the
variety
you can think of it as
inside cn and the number of generators
given by precisely these polynomial
equations
so spec simply means that you can define
this without
having to choose the system of
generators this is an intrinsic pro
construction
but you can think of this
these varieties in that way you have
explicit generators explicit relations
and evaluations gives you an algebraic
variety
this is it
so then
is it a caution so i want to think of it
as a quotient so i have a map
i have a quotient map
5 from x to y
which is the most natural thing you
like to do you take upon x and you look
at the values of
of your basis of invariance
which is of the three points in y
and why
is that a caution map well since the
f1 to fn are g invariants this map will
be constant
on the g orbits
okay
so that's that's what we want to do when
i said that we would like an algebraic
variety x y which parameterizing the g
orbits
so implicitly i was thinking of
the map
i should have a map an algebraic map
from x to y
which contracts the orbits and the
fibers are exactly the orbits okay four
bits
this would be the ideal situation
an algebraic variety a quotient map and
the orbits are precisely the fibers
okay the pre-image of a point is one
orbit exactly and
a parameterized orbit like that
so here i'm
close to that i have pi is constant on
zero bits so it means that each fiber is
a union of orbits
but i would like to have only one orbit
okay and of course as was already
noticed this morning this cannot happen
if the orbits are not closed
okay so
problem is that pi does not separate
a little bit
from its closure let's
see here you have an orbit like that
image orbit is the image of g by point
and something which is in the boundary
here
well each in each g invariant polynomial
is constant on the orbits
so we'll take the same value of course
on the limit point y
okay so already we have a series problem
if
if we have orbits which are not closed
then this uh
this method
starting from the space of the algebra
of inverse does not work it does not
construct
an orbit space
so at least
so it's still a good construction maybe
i could say state that as a theorem
so i want to be technical but uh you can
say that traditional
terminology that was a categorical
quotient
i will tell you what it means
so categorical caution means that you
cannot do anything better in this
situation
so it means that if you have some
other map
pi prime algebraic map to some y prime
which is co which is constant
on g orbits
okay so for for all such map
all candidate to be
a quotient then there will be some
factorization like this
the map will be first this map
pi composed by some other map
and inside a map well loses some
information
so this question is really the best
thing you could do
in this context
so the second
thing i would like to mention is that pi
my pi separates
closed orbits
you could have
an orbit here which is not
closed so which has another
maybe a closed orbit in this closure
okay so by pi they go to the same point
but if you take another
closed orbit here
it will go definitely clue to another
point
does not separate orbit closures
it separates closed orbits two different
two closed orbits different
are mapped to different points
it's two different questions so you
could try to separate it orbit from its
closure or you could try to separate two
different enclosures
if you have two of these
they can share a closed orbit
and you actually have another orbit
which has o second in this in its
closure and it goes to the same point if
your enclosures intersect
then they'll map to the same point the
orbit closures do not intersect it will
separate them
fibers are exactly the union of orbits
which which have a given closed orbit in
their closure
me
and this
so this very nice property follows i
could mention that by the from the
directly from the reynolds operator that
we made this morning
so maybe i should
the renounce operator there is a
slightly different way to see it
so from the here from the algebra
functions to the algebra in variance
more generally you can take any uh
financially generated g algebra and
maybe it
will be mapped to the ring of influence
with some nice properties
and you can
reductive groups you can think of these
as those for which any representation is
semi-simple any representation
reductive means that
any representation is over the complex
numbers
it's semi-simple which means that it is
a direct sum of irreducible
representations
so we have a
good understanding and this will be
important in all the theory
of representations of reductive group we
just have to understand the irreducible
ones and those are parameterized by some
combinatorial data so
situation the theory is very well
understood
so from this we have that um
we can apply this to r
and we can decompose
there is a direction direct sum of r
into the
one part being the sub algebra of
invariance
and we have a
direct factor r prime
which is the direct sum of all the
non-trivial irreducible representations
okay so there is a canonical
decomposition
some of
non-trivial
reducible representation
we have this canonical
decomposition and what is the reynolds
operator
it is just the
projection defined by this decomposition
okay so why do i mention that this point
of view is useful because it makes
obvious another
property of the reynolds operator which
is that if you take some
let's say s
any
subspace of r which is g invariant
okay so
by the same uh probably rejective groups
i can decompose it as
in exactly the same way i take the
invariance on one side and on the other
side the some of the
non-trivial
summons in the in s i have this
decomposition and the renault separator
the very construction sense s to sg okay
it was a priori so what i just want to
stress is that a priori the reynolds
operator would map it to rg
but in fact it goes to
sg which is contained in s
so if you apply the reynolds operator to
some gene of variant
you stay in this subspace
why does it implies why does it imply a
the second statement
because suppose you have
so i call this o prime
o seconds
two seconds so two closed orbits these
joints
there are two close
some varieties of my vector space x
empty intersection
so what i know from hillbert neuster
landsat
is that
i can find
some
obvious reason for which there are
the intersection is empty which is that
i can find some
okay so let's say that the uh ideal of o
prime is generated by a g1
gk
a little bit of a second by
h1
hl
so i can find some
relation by the hillbottom challengers
sum of g i i
plus some of
h j h j
equal one
which makes obvious the fact that the
intersection is
empty because on the intersection i
would add all the gi's all the a j equal
to zero
so i get one equals zero
okay so this is in the
modulo o prime this is in the ideal a
second
but then i can apply the reynolds
operator to this sum
i will write
1 as five prime projection of this by
the reynolds operator
this is jane's variant so this is still
by the remark i've just made
inside the ideal and g invariant
and this one is inside the ideal of a
second generate
okay
i find two
functions g invariant
one vanishing on
o prime the other vanishing on the
second
and the sum is one so this this implies
that pi really separates
i have two val two two functions will
take different values of my on the two
orbits
which exactly mean that pi separates
these two orbits
so good news and bad news and
why is the
best thing that i can do it has a nice
property but still we have this problem
so what essentially what gid
geometric tv
theory tells you is given a variety
in a general setting well you will not
be able to construct an algebraic
quotient
you will have to
give up some points
so you will you'll need to restrict to
some sub-variety
that you want to be as as large as
possible and then on these several you
will be able to
to do the quotient on jetty tells you
some recipes to do that in the best
possible way
so i would just like to make a few
remarks
in order to understand which is this
what could be this this open subset
on which we
we will have to restrict to
to have a good quotient
so to have no bit space to be precise
there's a fundamental
fundamental property of
algebraic maps
if you take an algebraic map between
some
will not be completely precise but
imagine you have some
like this between two irreducible
algebraic varieties
adjustable algebraic varieties
yeah then the point is that the fibers
are well behaved
so simplify there is a another subset
in which
the fibers
are constant dimension
and outside this open set so the
fibers
will have different dimensions but the
point is that the dimension can only
become bigger
picture will be like that you have some
eggs so in x you have some
fibers or maybe not irregular but
the same dimension
and somewhere that can be
on an open on a closed subset so why
there
can be some fibers which are a bigger
dimension
and if you go deeper to some
smaller close subset you can have some
even bigger even loud even fibers of
even larger dimensions
in this case
or any other result
you want concrete example
determinant is an example
okay so let me give you a statement and
then
you will have the determinant will be an
example
the first statement is apply this to
the the action so you have a
x suppose that you you have this group
acting on x and so you have the the map
you take an element of the group an
element in the variety you map it to gx
x
but this is an algebraic map
and what is what is a fiber so i want to
look at a special fiber fiber point
xx
what is that this is a so what you want
is to have gx equal x
so it's
the element of the group such that gx is
equal to x
we denoted gx the stabilizer of x
this tells you that so the state in the
statement tells you that the stabilizer
on some open subset the stabilizer has
constant dimension
and there is a closed subset on which
the stabilizer becomes bigger
that when you specialize the stabilizer
can only become bigger
in terms
okay let me give this statement i will
give you the example
that's for stabilizer but it may be
better to think of it in terms of orbits
your bits of a point x it's essentially
the same thing as the quotient of the
group by the stabilizer
you divide by the stabilizer so this
tells you that
the orbits has constant dimension
the dimension can only become smaller
consumption
only become smaller
that's typically what happens in this
context so
what's the example let's
let's think of c star acting on an o x
equal the
space of dimension n
max color multiplication
so what are the orbits well they are
just lines
they have a constant dimension there is
one special orbit which is the damage
which is zero
and in this case well you can
what does the construction give
nothing the algebraic inverse is just
the algebra functions
constant function so by when you apply
pi you go to one point
because every so every orbit has zero in
its closure
by scaling you can go to zero
think in terms of invariance so
every invariant map is constant
but set x point x
x x is a closed subset of x square
so you cannot apply this this way so you
cannot say that there is open subset of
x uh
of course i can apply it and then
intersect with the diagonal
yes but it may be an empty intersection
sure but i'm looking to these fibers
section is not empty you always have one
the stabilizer stabilizer is never empty
so another instance of this
statement is imagine you have some
orbit space
let's say constant on g orbits
so this means that any fiber
so this is not the same wise before this
is a different wine
yeah
okay actually something generally quite
something
okay so here you can observe that since
pi
is constant on g orbit and if fiber is
as an action of g it's preserved by g
so what we know is that
it's constant dimension on an open
subset
so this means that if you want
to have an orbit space so if you want
each fiber to exactly one orbit
then
this dimension must be the dimension of
the generic orbit the same one
is the dimension of the generic fiber
and then the other fibers would be a
bigger dimension of bigger dimensions so
if i
if we think that
the picture would be that in the fiber
we have a
an orbit plus
possibly something in the closure
this is excluded by this
we have something in the fiber which is
something an orbit of dimension d
suppose this orbit is not closed so we
have something in the boundary
then i have a contradiction
because the
other orbits
i know there are smaller dimensions
possible only
so we can have an orbit space
only if the the orbits have constant
dimension
this tells you that if you want to make
a caution you have to get rid
all the orbits which are pathological in
the sense that the dimensions is
smaller than the generic one
so an example is the determinant because
the dominant has uh some stabilizer
which is bigger than
the stabilizer a generic polynomial
so previously those the determinant is
something we would like to get rid of to
get rid of when we make a culture
yes but yeah so
there's some
let me come to some intermediate notions
so we will not exactly get rid of them
so we don't want really to completely
get rid of them but
so we will allow to have something
weaker than really an orbit space
so the definitions are
so maybe let's take the context so sorry
we
the theory is what we have ins for
projective varieties let's say
so take a projective variety
so the difference is that we are some
projective space
and our variety is given by some
step polynomial equations but which are
homogeneous
polynomial equations
and we suppose that
we have an action of a reductive group g
on x
and this action comes from a linear
action
on v
as we are in this uh simple situation we
have a
representation of g we look at your
projectivization and inside something
which is
stabilized by by the action of g
okay so we can still look at
polynomials on v
then they are no longer functions on x
okay they're not exactly functions
because of this
axis in the projective space
but still we can
be interested in that
no longer functions
but still we are going to use them so
the first definition
that
the point x is said to be semi-stable
if
so there is some invariant polynomial
that does not vanish on this point
okay so before going the second giving
the second part of the definition let me
make one remark
which is that
in this definition there is a kind of
interplay between what happens in the
projective setting and in the affine
setting
so here we have x in a
p of v
but we can
so given by some polynomial equations
you can look at the polynomial equations
and
what they've defined in in v itself
so there is an affine algebraic variety
x star
defined by the same equations
so 1 over x if you wish
under the same equation
okay and since i started with an action
of g and v
this is also
down with the g action
okay and each time i have a point here
i can choose a non-zero point which i
denote by x star
on zero
such that x is
born in projected space corresponding to
x star
and there is so there is an interplay
between the action of g on x star and
the action of g
so here if i have a so here i should
have written
p of x star
this really makes sense
and
so i'm reduced to the previous citation
when i look at the defined variety and
the set of
invariant polynomial in this variety
and so what does mean this condition it
does exactly mean that
when i have remember i have my
factorization
okay so i have zero going to zero
and saying that precisely mean that
x-star is not mapped to zero
since
i prove to you that uh the map
discussion map separates the closed
orbit this means that
the closure of the orbit of x-star
does not contain zero
exactly equivalent to this
i could imagine that i have some
some points in g
making it too close as possible to as
close as possible to zero and this
should not happen for semi-stable points
so
somehow
you want
g to be like sl instead of gl then or
something
can be defined for reductive group and
it's clear that if i take gln so i'll be
in trouble
so
that's a good remark if i
want to hope for the existence of any
semi-stable point i need
that my group does not contain scalars
okay so
this would be the important part
so are you imagining a situation where
you know the invariant ring and it's
easy to find such a certificate that
you're semi-stable or the other way
around
no no hi
finding the inference is always
too difficult
so i want to try to understand the
quotient without computing the
invariance
so somehow you're going to be able to
tell whether something is semi-stable
without producing yes
try to give you some recipes
the second thing is that
that works only very special cases
we need very special cases but uh yeah
but we only study special cases so
it works in case we care about
but i want to stress that what i will
stress on a few minutes is that the
probability we want we really are
interested in is that the orbit
of the point corresponding to
determinants of permanence are closed
so here you see that there is natural
condition on the boundaries and probably
have been closed which appear here
in fact that's another definition which
is that
x is poorly stable
if semi-stable
except for zero
and the orbit is closed
i should make a remark about that and
insist on this definition because uh
so the terminology is not
completely well established well
what i should say that there's the
fundamental book by uh
manfrotto on geometric invariant theory
and the terminology which is used in
that book is not the terminology which
is used in
modern treatments of the theory so there
can be some confusion
okay so
the most common terminology for this
property gx star being closed is called
a polystable
so
the last definition is a willy not
mumford
point is stable
if
so it's a police table
and
the stabilizer is finite
okay so
most text about git you will focus on
this notion of
stability stabilizer is not always is
supposed to be finite and this is not
always the case in the situation we're
interested in typically
dominant and permanent have infinite
stabilizers
so actually what why is there semi
stable in the second point
just to avoid zero
x is the projective
okay so the main so the main theorem
of git
is uh
so if i take the resistor quotient this
is the categorical quotient
same is device of a semi-stable locus
and it restricts to
no bit space
under stable locus
i really want to mention this theorem
because that's one of the coordinating
point of the theory so it tells you that
you can do a quotient it
tells you exactly
oh there are some salaries here but
which points you you have to keep to be
able to make these quotients
it tells you that you have really in
orbit space when you restrict to the
so i'm
highly stable
points
okay
then you can be more precise and say
that
precisely what happened on the
semi-stable but non-stable locus and
this has very
precise things to do with polystability
that's i don't want to talk about it
so maybe the first
last thing i want to mention is that the
quotient is very projected
something very important in the
applications you get a modular space so
you
tell you that
the construction is really good because
you want to exclude some points but it's
clearly if you
throw away too much points in the end
you will not get a compact space
chassis gives you when you start from
projective variety you end with a
projected modular space so let's
tell you that the construction is very
good
okay
and maybe a
little example that we already
made this morning if you look at the
adjunct action so that's xg called sl2
so
sl2 the mattresses of
tray zero
traceless mattresses
projectivize the action
then
think about it so
what's
beyonce said this morning you should see
exactly the picture so this action is by
conjugation black conjugation yes sure
do you mean the algebraic
of the group and it's a
space of traceless mattresses
okay so
yes so i can answer
give a few hints about uh
question when you want to
the other another example would be to
look at
what you're going to tell us
and this uh
that's an exercise that have been done
this morning already
my question is how is this exactly that
smallest what this example is
yes discuss this morning so you have two
invariants you have one invariant
how this example reflects the discussion
that we had before the example per se we
had
how does this reflect the whole analysis
yes so
yeah so remember you have the
the the
null coin
which is that the the space of uh
important mattresses
okay you had the caution map which was
given by
either the determinant of the trace of
the square
pi from sl2 to c
given by
taking a matrix m to the square
to the trace of this square
okay so this is
so i wanted to mention this example
because i you have
in this case you have a
so it's a bit too small but you have
according to jordan decomposition you
have your matrix is either
diagonalizable with a non-zero
eigenvalues
it can
be just to this form or it's zero
okay so geometrically you have so you
have zero of course then you have the
important cone
which is a dimension two
and then you have all the other
orbits
okay so what you want what you will
throw away is this part
and then you have a well well when we
have cautioned all the orbits are
two-dimensional
so at least in default file setting you
the question given by c-star
i want so you see
that what i noticed is that we have to
throw away the orbits that don't have
the right dimension but this is an
example tells you that you have to
throw away more orbits okay n is a
correct dimension but still you have to
right here you're acting on tracing
so there's just one environment the
quotient is the point
so i wanted to give
the example of binary forms briefly
okay so
so very briefly today to
answer the questions so
start with c star acting on v
okay so in this case we know that the
action can be diagonalized
so when you have some
so row of t so the map row is given by
in some basis your matrix will be given
by
mattresses or some exponents
e1 en
integers so v as dimension m
okay so when you uh take a point x-star
so you can decompose it into
respectively to this decrement with
respect to this decomposition
okay so some
some components will have zero i keep
only the the ones that
non-zero
and then i get some
exponents
and when
you have zero in the closure well of
course when
all the exponents are positive
okay so zero
is in the closure exactly
so so the di's are some of the e i's but
i kept only the x m x x
and which are nonzero
so you can see this and you can see that
if
if di if
so let's say if d1
put it inside put them in some order and
the smallest one is zero
like that
so you see that when t goes to zero
will converge to
the point x m
the orbit is not cl the orbit is not
closed
then you can say a little more because
the x m
is in x it's a limit point
and then we have an action is uh
if they're all negative it's not farther
this component here but if all the gi's
are negative strictly negative
oh so then it's also in the closure
zero
okay
i are negative for sure well you got
definitely there
okay so if i have this situation and
they're not all positive and the
smallest one is zero then the limit i
have a limit point which is obviously
stabilized by c star
okay so
yeah i contradict the semi stability and
here i contradict the stability because
i have
something non-trivial in the stabilizer
okay so
what you use in practice to decide if a
point is stable or unstable is the
contour the converse statement which is
the
hilbert mumford criterion
so the remark is that if you
your group g is typically a group of
metrics or mattresses so
a generic mattresses is diagonalizable
okay so up to conjugacy you will cover
your
the group by
mattresses which are diagonalizable
and then you can
add is torah
so we'll be sloping here you will
be able to
look at these uh typically these
examples
so there is a map from sistar to
your group
which is exactly given by
this kind of action
and this is uh the idea there's these
mattresses there are there is cadence in
g so if you can understand what happens
for all these
one parameter subgroup that you will
control what happens for the whole of g
this is the hilbert memphis criterion so
you call this
this dm notation is that
lambda with respect to the point x
you have two parts which is that x is
stable if an only if
mu x lambda is a
negative
lambda
semi-stable
and only if
zero
so what we've seen for
projection of c star itself
in fact
controls what happens for the whole
group if you look at all the one
parameter sub groups
and you can go in the reverse direction
so in practice you use this
okay so as i mentioned for the poly
stability we
that's an intermediate property and the
hilbert mumford criterion does not allow
you to decide if a point is poorly
stable
so there is a more refined
theory due to camp
which can be applied in this uh setting
so the idea is to look at the so suppose
we have
suppose that x is
uh x is a non-semi stable
so
zero is in the boundary of
a little bit of
x-star or suppose even that we have a
non-police stable
so it works
because you have some points
which is in
in the closure but not in the orbit
and you can and this means that you can
find some uh you have x-star
and you can find some one parameter
sub-group which
maps you in the limit to
what
so the game series
is uh very vaguely
is the study of
the
uh
the speed at which lambda goes to to y
so there's so you can introduce some
tool that can can control the speed
and it proves that
there is one
when up to some equivalence there's one
parameter sub group which goes faster
than
faster than all the other ones
and then the upshot is that
it's a bit technical soon
there is there is one lambda so up to
normally up to equivalence
maximum speed
sorry
up to this equivalence yes it's a
and then when you have a one parameter
subgroup
well it defines what is called a
parabolic subgroup because
which simply means that you have some
some subgroup of matrices like that
this is a parabolic subgroup group of
super triangular matrices by blocks and
this is precisely given by the order
of the exponents here
so nothing very
very deep but there is a parabolic
subgroup and it is unique
so since it is unique
unique implies
preserved by the stabilizer
by conjugation it will give you another
parabolic there is the same property so
by units uniqueness it's in in the
normalizer and the consequence is that
parabolic are known to have to be their
own normalizers so this gx is contained
in the parabolic
so this gives you camps camp steering
if gx is not contained
in a parabolic subgroup
and axis ballistic
okay so in particular if you have a
parabolic subgroup you have one subspace
which is preserved by the stabilizer so
if you can exclude that you have one
subspace
add stabilizers and automatically your
point is polystable
that's an important property we need for
uh
dominance and permanence
and it's difficult to see that
permanence and so permanence and
determinants that do not distinguish any
space of mattresses
especially because the stabilizer is big
enough if you wish
supplies that the
diaper is stable
the determinants are seen as a point in
the space
of the n polynomials in the space of
n square variables
both police table
which is an important point
should be precise for the action
special in your group
what about the paddocks
yeah so the padded permanent so
so this is a remember perm
rotation so still in v so you you have a
matrix
x
and by n so you just keep the block
and i am here
say some x so
the permanent
m
for m by m matrices i apply it to y
and i
so the degree n polynomial by
multiplying by
x 1 1 to the n minus m this is the
palette prominent
this one is obviously
not polystable
because you see that x 1 1 and y they
are independent set of variables
but obviously you can get some
degeneration to
firm
m y
let's say x n n
to the n minus m
take a degeneration of x one one to this
one
and obviously this is this is not in the
orbit this is in the old bit closure but
not in the orbit because this is
one less variable
so uh so this is not polystable but so
ketan proposed
a theory of partially stable
well partially polystable points
so here we can it is not polystable but
we know exactly why it is not fully
stable just because we added more
variables
so we can
control this and in the in the theory of
obstructions when we find lower bounds
for
the dominant vs permanent problem this
is not really an issue
you can essentially do like
the permanent as the padded permanent
was police table
absolutely i don't have much time to
explain that
so the last thing i want to briefly
explain is the
how to extend the finite generation
statements to more general
non-reductive groups
and explain why it is useful
finiteness for non-generate for
non-reductive groups
so remember that when g is reductive
our
algebra final type
then the algebra of invariance is also
finite type
so that's the theorem of professor popov
that essentially this is
characterization of reductive groups
they're always fine
algebra for which this does not hold
but there's a
slightly better situation when we can
still
hope for positive results suppose you
have a h non-reductive
but
a subgroup of a reductive group
we
are a g algebra finite type
and adjust the h algebra but g algebra
then
then we can ask in this restricted
situation is h of finite type
i want to give you an example where this
works
so there is a
nice statement which is called the
transfer principle
which is that
here's a natural map from the
tensor product
type the algebra functions on g
answer by r
and take the invariance of g
for the diagonal action
there is a map from r there's a natural
map which is uh here i take a function
i have a essentially an element
i'll i'm happy to just evaluate the
function on the unit element of g
the statement is that this is an
isomorphism
and when i have a
subgroup of g this there is a
direct extension of this statement which
is that you can put h in variance on
both sides
so this is nice because you replace the
problem of having of taking a
h invariance into the problem of taking
g invariance
something which is bigger
but the consequence is that
c of g h is finally generated
so that that's the problem that's not
always true consequence if
precisely the algebra of inference is
finally generated
then i can conclude
the change in variance in r or finally
generated
when can this be true so c of g
okay so this is the algebra functions on
the quotients by h
so when is it finally generated
certainly not always
this caution can be
can have very different types of
algebraic varieties we can have
projective varieties we can have a fine
variety so for example if if gmod h is a
fine
okay if gmo h is a fine
already precisely those which are
which are given by finitely generated
algebra functions
so we could apply this theorem
in fact we have nothing new because this
is known to be equivalent
to the fact that h itself is reductive
so nothing new
but we can
ask that gmatch be close to be fine
because that's that
so
the best situation would be that
tumult would be a subset of an affine
variety
and very close to it which means that
could i mention
of the complement
is at least two
so we have this a fine variety and we
get rid of uh small uh subsets and we
get this and this orbit
then
then the same conclusion holds because
sorry for uh
we have to change z use it a little bit
but we will get the the space of
functions on g mod h will be this the
algebra functions of the normalization
of them
situation it is projective yeah but if
it is projective you don't get any
invariant
nothing interesting
yes very close to be a fine so very far
from being
projected yeah so and the normalization
is a is a file it's a classical theorem
so in this case you
hear the statement what is this
no normalization
is that h is parabolic so
h is parabolic
the variety is projective and you don't
get any invariant
okay so this was uh so think for example
so when when do we have this situation
where g mod h is containing z a fine so
you could think it it's a
artificial hypothesis but if you have
any stabilizer so suppose
suppose g acts on a
vector space v
you have a linear action
and you can take
any stabilizer
gx is the orbit of x it's contained in
the closure which is a fine
question is when is the boundary of
could i mention at least two
well for example you could take a
equal c2 with the action of sl2
you can take x to be
vector one zero
okay well by the action of sl2 you can
send this vector to any vector
except zero
we are precisely in this nice situation
where the
boundary just zeros could i mention at
least two
so this works
the stabilizer
what is the space of mattresses
of this kind usually denoted here
so we deduce that
at the uh
h is a
space of invariant and space of
polynomials
in two variables
are
not sl2
we prove that
so that's a finite generation statement
for non-reductive groups
so if you take are any irreducible
representations of binary forms
you prove that this is the algebra of
covariance algebra
and so this is finally generated
so this is a very ancient theorem it is
due to roberts around
i think
algebra the
covariant algebras of binary forms is
finally generated
but the idea can be applied in a much
more general setting so
just
just say very briefly
and i will stop
with that
in what context i would like to apply it
so suppose b is
cn again g will be sln
and
the w to be so cn plus
h2 of cn etc i take the direct sum of
the watch powers
i will take my point x to be
e1 plus
one which e2 i chose the basis
like a sum of in the compo of
decomposable
decomposable tensors like this
well so it's just an exercise to check
that
the stabilizer is again this group of
upper triangular matrices with one on
diagonal
and two holes
see
our g major is finally generated
so you can apply this to get to control
some
other algebras of covariance
so maybe first we can say that uh what
is exactly this algebra
we have the
perivale pedophiles theorem
which is really an exercise which tells
you that
c of g is the sum over all the
irreducible representations
of the star tensor v
when you go to uh
quotient map you just
get the invariance
sorry i'm
out of time so i'm being
a little too quick here but this is uh
just
one dimensional so it doesn't know a bit
about representation theory this is just
one dimensional
and there is a
an action of t which is given by the
highest weight of the representation
it's a line with with a
an action of c star and this algebras
essentially the sum of all the reducible
representations
so we know this is finitely generated
application let's take three copies of
it
is a maybe
look at eight answer eight and so a
this is the sum of
so a is the sum of uh
sorry so i wrote it like this but as i
mentioned the v's the reducibles they
are really parameterized by
combinatorial data which are the highest
weight
of lambda where lambda all the possible
i straight tensor
some venue
tensor
menu
so i can put duals does not change
anything
okay so i can
take the invariance now in these triples
is the sum over all representations i
can do lies it's just an evolution
okay so i get this so
a is financially generated so this
triple product is i take the invariant
of gln so it still gets something
finitely generated
it's finally generated
and when do i have something here
based on zero exactly if and only if v
new
is contained in the tensor product of v
lambda and so v mu
so there's something which is you
usually denoted the little wood with
charts on code or glm or slm
set of triples lambda mu nu
such that
new
news containing the product of vlander
and vimeo
this is the weight
space the set of weights
of this finally generated algebra
so since it is an algebra when i take
the wax i get a semi group
since the algebra is a finite type i get
a semi group which is financially
generated so finite type
this nice statement due to brilliant
the
space of weights is semi group of finite
types so that's really a generalization
of this
term by robots and you can apply it in
more general situations for example for
chronicles
please
so
no i speak